yeah
ah that's it look at we coordinated our
outfit will be your new 90s girl duo
scarfs and scarfs for all of you that
don't know this is my mother
hey thank you I get my awkward hands
well I'll do this we look like a
terrible morning talk show right now I
came home from the holidays it's fast
new year's it's 2014 but my mom whoopee
my mom had these at home make your own
gingerbread man kit a little late to
make holiday gingerbread men but we
thought that we could make New Year's
resolution gingerbread men sure why not
we're turning lemons into lemonade
choices so my mom and I are going to
decorate to gingerbread men that
happening Year's resolutions and then
you guys are going to judge who did it
better
can you explain these rules to me yeah
your goals okay okay ready
I'll listen there are no rules what you
can't be my rules to follow up you have
to decorate your gingerbread men with
the theme New Year's resolutions okay
okay I got it and that's the only rule
okay okay but you said there's no okay
wait we have to get ourselves in the of
the spirit of New Year's top of the
morning to you oh my god commence
decorate a do you have a plan no that's
my point every other icing that's really
nothing right icing no you know but what
is right and what is wrong
so thanks
because now there's no rules slow murder
is wrong don't do that
put the knife down do I want my
gingerbread men to have green eyes or
blue eyes or red eyes are you working oh
well the red
wellthat is she met that's what she said
have you ever heard that right
it's that oh it's okay it's old it's
basically like a way to talk about sex
mmm oh no the yellow and everywhere
people in the box we're having more fun
than this what are some of your new
year's resolutions
- resolution yeah you're losing this Oh
get back a good help Oh what does that
mean
oh my eights and pains I need to work on
getting rid of them you have any new
year's resolutions um just like be less
perfect how could that possibly happen
grace I don't know good I hate gonna
stop good I get theme is New Year's
resolutions you look like you're just
making generic gingerbread me okay some
people do internal runs okay I'm done oh
my god okay I'm almost done what I I
need one more piece what do you do wait
wait now I'm done let's explain our
gingerbread men shall we you go first
okay might injure bread man had the New
Year's resolution I'm trying to lose
weight and get in shape and you did a
really good job and then you realize
that Yolo I love cake tada
so now you explain yours okay hi guys
Lola's brewery oh god I'm amazing
give me anything on the outside okay
right
this thing is more internal freeze what
things believing from the mouth oh man
you're making fun of my mom's and admin
has tuberculosis Liang Liang clacks his
thing was eat less sweets yeah good
office to your teeth it makes your gums
bleed resolution if I see a dentist
yeah Twilight people people this goddamn
mess well there you have it their new
year's resolution gingerbread men let me
know in the comments if you think mine
is better than my mom's or if my mom's
is better than mine we tried what are
some air New Year's resolutions I don't
care you do you I don't know I don't
know you don't want to talk to you about
what I saw this really really really
cool trailer for a new movie oh yeah oh
my god it's so amazing it from what I
could see from the trailer uh I was
these three really cute very talented
girls uh-huh ladies okay do they look
like they're working at a camp okay it
wasn't on First Wives Club you think I
was cool I think was called camp
something okay huh yep Kim uh-huh okay
Camp Takota
okay and I have to say I like I love the
three girls but there was just one girl
in particular she is so fabulous I mean
I just couldn't sell bodger
she's just so nice and I can't wait for
the movie to come down okay do you think
you'd like to see it oh yes this is
where as my mom does a bit everyone